next red pill moment that i had
was that the pay gap doesn't exist it
doesn't exist yeah okay so
yeah so and that women
arguably have more power in society than
men
we talked about this last time so
i think when you put the statistics up i
was like well when you put it like that
that is very true
so yeah i don't think
um there is a pay gap
yeah that's behind it it's really weird
it's like some of the stuff they leave
out it's just like how can you leave
that out and have a genuine honest
question i think they do it to get money
out of it like feminists i think they
they use the pay gap to get money
there's no way they can be
putting that stat on such a big platform
like if i even say one stat that's a
little off i get comment after comment
after comment telling me where i went
wrong
so i don't know how i don't know how and
yeah usually they don't really talk
about the why i said they don't really
talk about the why maybe it is because
of the money um i think i remember
watching uh
jordan peterson
and um
and he was talking to a woman about and
she was she wanted them to acknowledge
that it's there wasn't the water
uh it was channel four
oh
oh yeah that's the that's the one we
watched jess the first one the second
one the uh
kathy newman cathy newman
and i think it was a thing of what
you're trying to say yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the one yeah
so i think it's a thing of
they want people to just
be like oh it's there and that's the
problem that's there like
but obviously he jordan peterson was
talking about you have to talk about why
it's there there's always a way to
understand so nothing happens because it
just happens yeah like you have to
understand why and the mess behind yeah
because they because basically like they
don't take into account when they when
they do the pay gap all they did was
divide how much how many women there are
based on how much the average they just
took the average of how much women make
and the average of how much men make put
them together and said oh there's a gap
it must be discrimination
but what they didn't talk about was who
works longer hours what jobs do they
pick are there personality traits that
that
include that make it
harder for women to make more money and
so one of those is the trade
agreeableness
so it women
60 of women have never asked for a raise
and they'll quit their job before they
ask for a raise
so the trade agreeableness is basically
like your ability i think jordan
peterson says it means you're kind
caring compassion and polite and those
people work better with people but they
don't ask for raises and they don't take
control of situations as well
it's kind of like i always say on a
basketball team the bitchiest girl is
always the captain
because she's always the one that's
going to take charge yeah and that's and
that's a really good trait to make money
yeah and and men tend to do that more on
a law of averages okay so between that
they work longer hours they pick harder
jobs of course they're gonna make more
money
and it's funny because
you see women complaining about the pay
gap but they never talk about the gap
um and between women make more money and
modeling
where's the equality
i work in construction i'm a quantity
surveyor and i'm also studying
and when i tell you in a class full of
like 100 people i can assure you there's
about eight girls
in the entire class right and i think
that's pushing it and maybe like nine
maybe six
but like
there's not many and
what i do makes a lot of money yeah and
it's like okay if i know that
right and these girls who are in this
room know that and it's a thing where
everyone knows that once you get
qualified from this once i get charted
my payraise basically doubles if i want
to if i want to go other places right
because i'm basically i've become a
specialist but it's like
if you're not putting the work to become
that specialist to become that person
that is sought after value-wise
monetarily-wise
then how can you say that you deserve
the money because it's like
i
if i put in
six extra hours
in a week than you do
how many more hours does it add up to in
a month
how many more hours does that add up to
in six months yeah and in two years
we'll never catch up never catch up
and there's also the problem where they
can't keep women over a certain age
um jordan peterson talks about how there
were lawyers in canada like high paying
professional lawyers
and over it was like 30 to 35
they couldn't pay these women to stay
because they said okay i have enough
more money than i know what to do with
i want to go spend time with my family
they can't pay to keep them
[Music]
and that goes into the personal choices
females females really that they want to
be around family and if they can you
know take time off to be to have a
family and it's not the weirdest thing
about the the the um
wage gap thing they don't even take into
account how it's worked yeah
like we can be in the same job but i
have a 40 hour a week contract and you
have a thirty year old contract and they
won't even take into account the ten
hours contracted difference between you
guys they would just say that oh you
made me want even i made more money than
you and you're on the same position oh
how dare i it's like um
you work four days a week i work five
years
[Laughter]
of course i'm gonna get paid more than
you why would i not pay you get pay more
and once you start to see this you start
to realize that everything in society is
female centric because women make 70 to
80 of consumer buying decisions
so every scene everything we see in the
media is geared towards women
so think about it do do men want to see
fat chicks on the cover of magazines
sports magazines yeah
do they want do they want to see ashley
graham
or is that smasher pass ashley green
boys move in matthew what do they do in
the last and their last uh playboy i
don't know
i think it was i think it was i think it
was a sports illustration when they had
the old one because they were situation
one is one but like this was like
playboy's last attempt to like
be back in like the mainstream and i
think they got i think it was james
charles
recoverable playboy and i'm like gee i'm
like come on
the gay youtuber guy the makeup the
makeup guy he was like the first boy
yeah cover girl
oh
i think i think i remember you because
the thing is let's not get twisted i
rate james charles right person as a
human being that's what he does but like
there's a time in place
to put certain things right
and that just just isn't it no because
misogynistic it's like i'm not putting a
sweaty dwayne the rock johnson with his
shirt ripped off on the front of a
cooking book because he just does
shouldn't be there
like sure he you can put him there but
doesn't mean you should
that makes sense men are 23 times more
likely to die in the workplace than
women
[Music]
but you never see any marches about this
wow people
men get four times
the amount of jail
for their the same four times the amount
of sentencing for the same crime than
women i could see that
amber heard still out here
yeah she will ever walk i mean she's
broke now but she's not in jail yeah no
[ __ ] the um australia uh
uh they might do it for perjury crazy
oh really yeah because you know how she
lied about her dogs
yeah this is in australia i think after
the whole thing went down with the trial
i think they're going to actually bring
them up on the line to the police about
bringing their dogs in
yeah i mean they should i hope so i hope
they do but and even even the me too
movement
was that fair believe all women was that
fair
imagine imagine if the the slogan was
believe all men
imagine no but just just just just us
laughing here
like whenever i flip something it's
never okay like i'll have girls on this
show come on and say yeah like i hit him
but i've had girls admit to abuse on
this show and i always think if he came
in and admitted to abuse
the police will be honest
but women admit to it all the time
even even cheating if a man's a cheater
everyone tears him down on social media
if a woman cheats admits it look at the
comment section on tick tock it'll
always someone has an excuse for her
well maybe she wasn't happy
maybe this may be like
but for men they see that video of those
two girls who um
it's an american podcast and they
basically said if you cheat on your wife
you're a bad father
it's like huh
because you're not respecting her the
mother of your child it has nothing to
do nothing to do
yeah the child or being a parent yeah
does that mean i'm a shitty husband
maybe
but
but that doesn't make me a bad father by
any means by any means yeah i could be
there every single day but just because
i cheat on you doesn't mean that you're
a kid right or they even said
mlk oh yeah yeah
they were saying
mlk would i don't know if he said he was
a bad person he was a bad person and a
bad father because he didn't know what
to
do
martin luther king
husband and a bad father yeah yeah but
he was a good person he wasn't a really
good man because he wasn't he wasn't
good to his wife at all times no matter
what
let's flip it imagine if women talked
like they talked like this about a woman
who is very accomplished i i can't maybe
oprah i don't i know it's not the same i
couldn't think of one that was the
equivalent
i couldn't think of what but but oprah
was a bad person because she cheated on
a guy
oh david cause oprah was she admitted
that she was like a side check for a
little bit when she was younger
so
what what if
they said that they said oh her
accomplishments don't mean anything
because she cheated
they would doesn't change
they would go yeah
yeah but for some reason for men it's
okay
i saw them when i heard the martin
luther king one i was like wow
so when
when did they say he cheated all these
years martin luther king been dead now
all of
basically right this is this is again me
putting my tinfoil hat on
right
the fbi will um you know how the fbi
would like
like watching him at all times right so
the fbi back in the time
released a report i might be wrong right
again chat
tell me if i'm wrong they released a
report and basically because the fbi had
been tapping their phones and doing all
of that they basically made a report
saying that he's cheating on his wife
and then put it on the news to try and
defame him or like
make him look bad in the public so it's
one of those things where if do you
believe it's true or do you believe that
this is a story that the fbi put in the
news to make you believe it and now you
but even even if it was true it
shouldn't matter
maybe she knew like you know
and that's true the thing is there are
two black girls
that's like how dare you in a way like
he is the reason that you were able to
be on that camera and speak your truth
so i was like
how are you gunning the person who put
you in a situation that you're in right
now because he wasn't 100 a saint let's
say the story is true because he wasn't
a saint to every single person in the
world
then all of a sudden he's the devil
like now
i think obviously i think in hindsight a
lot of people can see like certain
things that for them to
i don't know i don't think they wanted
to counsel
martin luther king but like for them to
bring that up i think it's just
hindsight and it's just the privilege of
being in this kind of position where we
can talk on mics and stuff like that and
the hindsight is that you know they
don't really
you know
appreciate
what he's done
everyone knows how to see